[Musique]
certains jours sont plus heureux que
d'autres ce matinlà un groupe d'élèves
arrive en savate au collège Antoine
SOUBOU ma il est là desila Rachida
récupérer le matériel à travers leur
professeur de PS c'est l'action de
l'association sportive du collège qui
permet ses activités extrascolair et
légalement c'est le principal le
président de l'association c'est ition
qui permet aux élèves de pratiquer du
sport en dehors des cours de PS qui sont
dans les emploi du temps c'est
effectivement une bulle d'air dans la
mesure où les activités ne sont pas
notées donc il le font avec grand
plaisir mais ça n'empêche pas
l'engagement avec une autre dynamique
puisqu'ils sont volontaire donc il n'y a
pas la contrainte qu'on peut leur
imposer lorsqu'ils sont en cours et donc
de ce point de vue c'est extrêmement
[Musique]
bénéfique vous avez gagné vous allez
perdre on va gagner c'est sûr sûr allez
tout le monde dans le bus là tout de
[Musique]
suite cette initiative qui favorise
l'épanouissement et la réussite
éducative est financée par le Conseil
départemental et plus globalement c'est
l'UNSS régional qui est subventionné
vous allez sûrement consommer
aujourd'hui des des bouteilles des
machins à boire à manger vous ne laissez
rien il y a des poubelles il y en a
là-bas il va y avoir des poubelles dans
un instant déposé à à tous les
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
coins les échauffements sont originaux
mais ici c'est l'autonomie qui est
privilégiée pour ces 450 collégiens
bienvenue au jeu des collégiens de
l'Ouest et que vous remportiez ou pas la
compétition c'est pas grave l'essentiel
c'est que vous vous amuser aujourd'hui
on est
d'accord une image positive d'une
jeunesse consciente de sa chance de
profiter des dispositifs de l'UNSS là
ils sont dans un système de
fonctionnement associatif où ils vont
devoir justement apprendre ben le mode
de
fonctionnement les cons qui peut y avoir
les engagements aussi qu'il y a au sein
de de ce domaine et humainement
justement ça leur permet de de gagner
beaucoup en maturité par rapport aux
différentes expériences qu'ils peuvent
rencontrer de leur investissement au
sein bah de l'Association Sportive
elle-même puisque ils sont souvent
appelés soit à être par exemple
secrétaire adjoint ou trésorier adjoint
et aussi au niveau de l'organisation un
petit peu comme on a vu ce matin
c'est-à-dire que dispatcher les élèves
sur les sur plein de responsabilités
qu'ils n'ont pas en fait au sein des
cours qu'ils ont au sein de
l'établissement lui-même allez on
commence le jeu
[Musique]
ballon malgré le soleil les enfants
donnent le meilleur d'eux-même une plage
de sable blanc qu'ils n'ont pas tous les
jours
oui c'est un mix d'équipe d'accord c'est
bien que ce soit en mix oui c'est bien
on est presque
ég on est presque mais gar pres on est
presque ég n profiter s'amuser un peu
des cours non on n pas venu pour gagner
on est juste venu pour s'amuser voilà
être ensemble à la plage souvent
l'occasion de jouer dans le sable non
pas tout le temps
ouais
Béon ça est
dur non mais il fatigue
plus conna d'
personn que tu penses que tu vas
apprendre cette journé le fair le
respect de l'environnement le diabète la
diologie la nutrition leourisme et le
respect de l'environnement ça
aujourd'hui oui c'est écrit sur le
papier en
cas pour que pas tout le monde peut
venir
iciss just de permettre aux élèves de de
pratiquer pour pour qu'il ils accèdent
au partage à la convivialité et en fait
il faut qu'ils réussissent leur vie
associative donc je pense que l'UNSS est
l'un des éléments moteurs support en
fait de l'éducation de l'élève à la
citoyenneté cette nouvelle manifestation
de l'UNSS accompagnée par le Conseil
départemental est à nouveau la preuve du
rôle social et pédagogique du sport dans
notre
société
[Musique]